Speaker 1: Let's hear from a few more people
via the David Pakman show Discord, which you
can find at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
We are going to start right now right away
with no delay with Dylan from Kentucky.
Dylan, what is on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
I've been a long time, listeners.
First time I ever got to call and speak to
you, so I'd be a little shaky here.
Speaker 1: You're doing great so far, my friend.
Speaker 2: Thank you, friend.
So I think for a long time, it's sort of been
seen as as the linchpin for what might fix,
you know, our democracy.
Here is the issue of campaign finance reform.
And I wonder, I would like to get your thoughts
on how that can and will relate to the upcoming
Supreme Court decision on more versus Harper
and thus giving.
State legislators more power over our elections
in general.
And I would like to just mute and listen to
you talk about that for a moment.
Speaker 1: So one of the things when people
call in and they say, David, sir, you know,
sometimes they have tears in their eyes and
they say, what do you think are the most important
issues facing American politics?
The list that I've typically given over the
last few years, as I say, campaign finance
is one such issue.
Media coverage of politics is another issue,
and it's very much influenced by how we finance
elections.
Third is how we run our elections, meaning
first past the post in most cases, and also
the Electoral College for the presidency.
I would like to see that changed.
And fourth is climate change in the sense
that if your city is underwater or the pollution
in your city is so bad that it's going to
be hard to be an activist for the issues that
we care about unless we deal with climate
change in a in a sensible way.
And then sometimes we'll also talk about access
to health care, because if you're sick and
don't have access to health care, it's also
hard to be an activist.
Whether you care about education or abortion
or whatever, access to health care would also
be another issue.
I still stand by that, but I think that we
need to be much more sort of strategic when
we simply say campaign finance reform.
I almost think it's too broad for some people
to understand what we mean.
And so a much more specific but still understandable
set of ideas should be there.
And I think within that, the most important
ones would be public financing of elections
rather than, you know, just unlimited spending.
Whatever you can raise, you can spend.
So public financing of elections would be,
number one, doing everything we can to eliminate
the ability of dark money to come in right
now, even though there are quite strict limits
in terms of contributions directly to candidates.
I forget whether it's 2700 per cycle or exactly
what the number is.
There is the ability to donate huge amounts
of money to PACs and the money can sort of
be laundered and you don't know who's spending
what, where the money's coming from in all
cases necessarily.
So that's really where I would would try to
focus that conversation.
And to be honest, that I know now I'm getting
a little bit off the exact question.
I would like to see us the left become way
more specific and strategic with all of these
issues.
So like, for example, when we talk about climate
change or climate change, we should be more
specific in terms of what we're talking about,
because sometimes the things that are repeated
about climate change aren't really the biggest
concerns.
There's a really good book called The Precipice
by Toby Ord, which both argues I recently
read the book.
It's a couple of years old.
It both argues climate change is a massive
issue that we have to deal with.
And also some of the statements made about
it are a little bit hyperbolic.
For example, if climate goes, if it gets if
the climate gets warmer by two degrees on
average, we're going to starve because we're
not going to able to grow food.
When you look into that, actually it being
a little warmer would probably make it easier
to grow food in more parts of the world.
The issues are different ones and we should
try to be more specific.
And all of these all of these issues, I hope
to some degree I'm answering the question,
Dillon, and I hope to hear from you again
very, very soon